der Herbst kommt nach Deutschland und
die Menschen schlottern vor grasangst
deshalb auf nach Holzkirchen kann uns
das bayerische Brudervolk bei der
bundesweiten gasknappheit helfen
wir stehen hier gerade auf 650 Millionen
Kubikmeter Erdgas das könnte man fördern
und wir haben ja ein gasproblem momentan
ganz akutes wir importieren für sehr
sehr viel Geld Fracking Gas aus den USA
und ich glaube wir sollten auch die
heimischen vorkommen stärker nutzen sie
haben 650 Millionen Kubikmeter feinstes
Gas unter sich ist es da nicht ein
bisschen gefährlich jetzt hier sind
Feuer anzumachen
die sich hier abspielen so ist und unter
Rest fangen wir wieder an die Gase die
mentangase wir haben hier da drin und
jetzt sind wir unser Feuer ach so das
heißt also mit eurem methangasen macht
ihr hier dann das Feuer genau so ist das
ist so diese bayerische Öko denke so ist
es biologisch aktiv für die Umwelt war
letzte Woche beim hindelmeier Senf hat
es wahrscheinlich hier auch auf dem Fest
der sagt er kriegt am 1.1 kein Gas mehr
und ihr sitzt auf dem Vorkommen holen
wir es doch hier aus der Erde hade jetzt
geht es weiter bei uns ist ordensfakt
mir im vollautenland wir haben das
Marcel dass mir praktisch geht hier nie
Wärme fördern kannten dann brauche ich
das ganze Gas wieder ich habe erfahren
25 Prozent der Energieversorgung kommt
durchs geothermiewerk das heißt also 75%
müssen wir anders herkommen woher denn
eigentlich
ja diese schwierig aber wir haben ja
keine Ahnung ich bin kein
energiewissenschaftler aber wer zu
herkommen wir haben einen Ortstermin mit
Detlef Fischer vom bayerischen
energieverband der weiß warum in Bayern
energietechnisch alles am Arsch ist
immer die bayerische Staatsregierung hat
sich nach dem wenn wir uns so nennen
wollen nach dem woodbürger ausgerichtet
ja das was sie hierlich ähm ein Problem
da hätte ich ein faszinieren Vorschlag
man könnte ja wenn wir jetzt Energie
will kann man einfach auch den den
heißen Dampf der den würden gutbürgern
aus den Ohren kommt abzapfen und nutzbar
machen ne Oma hat ja wenn es hart auf
hart kommt immer noch Norddeutschland da
stehen die Windräder z.B da ist sehr
sehr dumm da können uns die Winterreifen
was gebt ihr im Gegenzug
Kinder ach so das ist also der Deal ihr
schickt uns den Strom und dafür dürfte
eine Woche hier zu vergünstigten Preisen
weil sie sind natürlich Mann der schon
normal wo steht denn hier das nächste
Windrad
Hofolding hinten also Richtung Minger ja
wie viel Kilometer ist es entfernt 35
vielleicht oder hätte das ja auch mal in
der Zeit also auch die
Aufopferungsbereitschaft der
norddeutschen auf eine gewisse Art und
Weise zu würdigen ja danke dass Sie uns
die Windräder zur Verfügung stehenden
so jetzt reicht Holzkirchen ich hole den
großen Bohrer raus und besorg mir das
soll
ach scheiße auf Holzkirchen ich bin
reich
[Musik]
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen ja das mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniere endlich den
verkackten heute schon
Kanal also geht doch